triple retrouvailles pour michel piccoli
22 ans après la cerisaie de tchekhov
s'il retrouve de taurus le même metteur
en scène et le même théâtre peter brook
donc et la scène des bouffes du nord
pour ta main dans la mienne et d'y jouer
tchekhov d'une prodigieuse vérité aux
côtés de l'épousé de peter brook
natasha parry reportage bruno la dref
frédéric bazille ça se passe comme ça
chez peter brook sur la scène des
bouffes du nord
un grand tapis trois chaises un bureau
et deux géants michel piccoli 78 ans il
joue l'auteur de théâtre russe anton
tchekhov
car natasha parry elle interprète sa
jeune épouse olga vous a trop gâté la
vie ordinaire ne n'est pas assez bonne
pour vous comme je souffre à cause de
mon travail
l'amour du dieu écrivait lorsque j'ai
fait connaître à ma fiancée séparé de sa
femme à cause de la maladie une
tuberculose lui interdisait les froids
d'hiver moscovite chekhov entretint une
riche correspondance avec olga un
échange de lettres qu'il a fallu adapter
pour le théâtre était leur liaison
continue 420 alex en six ans avec les
rencontres ce qui était atteint du mot
aux dates et youri t et d'émotions et
d'énergie de secret hier nous avons joué
vagne la pièce à succès fou toute assez
d'embraser rien à dire là-dessus
dans leur courrier l'auteur et l'actrice
évoqué leur métier leurs interrogations
leurs angoisses
l'homme et la femme parlait de leur
amour de l'absence de l'ourson chemin on
en sourit on en rit on s'émeut une heure
et demie sur scène michel piccoli et
natasha parry nous font vivre ce vrai
théâtre ou le temps des saisons passent
trop vite
avec toutes les choses qui vont de
travers
et de terrible chagrin mais vous devez
affronter a accepté de lagor continuer
le chemin